it's been 84 years I can still smell the
fresh paint uh what what are we doing
rehearsal yeah but for
what what is this we're doing a Titanic
party I'm just going through my lines
but can we do this I mean Riley can we
put him in white face I don't see a
problem with it it better be I've been
sitting in the crack for three
hours I remember the white face thing it
just seems like it's inversive the black
uh face for a face of someone of color I
don't know if that's a good are we sure
can we do this yeah we got rides okay
go fine you'll get us equal right no I'm
not against you of course
go for it I guess but just well the
other why why Titanic
I don't why because this is the widest
movie ever he's expanding his creative
range yeah just look at me
it looks great you
but here's the thing you're reading the
actual script
it's not a parody you have to change it
you have to change it we tweaked it yeah
I'm The Tweak but why are you dressed
like why are you the old lady
cause I got rats now
fine fine I don't
whatever
Keith Titanic sketch yeah she's gonna be
a train wreck huh I don't what are you
humming oh
I don't want that song in the actual
thing please I don't Casey I'm not Joe I
know what I'm doing because I don't want
him to sketch
okay okay I know but you're saying okay
but I think you're gonna try and put it
in anyway trust me don't I don't I don't
trust you it's not going in
I hate my life
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
remember none of this is possible
without you join the fight and sign up
for mug club today at louder with
crowder.com mug club for 89 annually
join the fight at louder with credit.com
mug club today
is from Zimbabwe that place is a show we
talk about my reparation for my
ancestors pain and suffering yeah it's
time for me to get paid time to make us
whole yeah damn that's just gay sending
me pictures of these flexors
you gay as hell I don't do that day
stuff but just cause you use
dumbass
you guys said that you voted for Obama
at least the first time right first down
second time Mitt Romney yeah oh wow oh
that's surprising because he's like the
whitest guy ever
I'm saying that mercury might be more
necessary than ever because YouTube has
become a liberal hole
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
oh that's uh why did I go no it's
actually it's good
I don't know why hey I guess we should
just usually do intros afterwards we'll
get into the topics but since you saw
the intro I think you probably know who
is uh if you hear this music in third
chair today their show is going to
launch here uh on mug club and of course
Rumble Hodge twins uncensored in October
at conservative twins Keith and Kevin
Hodge how are you Brothers we're doing
great thank you for having us can I say
brother I can say bro you can say
Brothers to everyone you're my brother I
say it and then I specifically don't say
it to black guys
[Laughter]
it's no problem bro bro yeah you're
doing a cool way I just hate it you know
white people as soon as he come and
always hey what's up my
French Canadian and my brother yeah and
they're like what what are you saying
one time there was a black man uh
playing piano and a black turtleneck
good looking guy kind of looked like Tay
Diggs and uh he was playing the piano I
did a beautiful rendition of O Holy
Night and then my mom when she was
living there was a black Usher uh also
wearing a black turtleneck she's like I
hey brother you did great on the piano
he was like okay thank you
all right so we have a lot to get to
today the burning man has turned into
well the lesser man the drowning man and
uh we're going to be talking about
Elon Musk is he the Savior that the some
people on the right have propped him up
to be or you know is there some good and
some bad uh you know Duality as they
call it in screenwriting or you know
people who take Humanities for the first
semester in college we'll get into kind
of the pros and cons and something that
I really want to talk about today uh
hopefully this is a reference piece so
you can use it the references are
available at lettucecrater.com
suicide in this country is we often talk
about mental health we often talk about
needing to to help people and and not
stigmatizing people who need help but
suicide is almost exclusively a white
male problem you know not including I
mean the transgender statistic
notwithstanding with that's less than
one percent of the population right
compared to white women compared to
women in general compared to black men
compared to black people brown people
Asian white men commit suicide at an
unbelievable rate if we want to solve
the suicide problem we need to start
acknowledging why white males
specifically white middle-aged males are
committing suicide in record numbers and
why do you think that is comment below
and then we'll have the segment here
coming up uh later in the show uh but I
think it's an important one all right
Gerald a number two how are you sir I'm
doing well I'm glad you came back to me
I I thought you might skip over me well
because you're a white man I thought I
thought I would look over and just be
dangling feet in a noose exactly like
well I wonder why they commit suicide at
such a high rate yeah well you know what
it's okay go deal with your vertigo that
was not fun I know I know you get the
vertigo I hate you too as well yeah not
you but you know you too yeah I still
have their album on my iPhone I don't
know how to get rid of it it just comes
with the phone I know it's disgusting
makes me want to burn the phone it's so
quadruple Platinum well that's because
you forced it on our phone all right big
YouTube fans Keith Kevin you guys are
you good you ready are you excited for
your show to be doing there on the
mugler yeah yeah because uh I mean
believe it or not we kind of sense
ourselves yeah like
in the knot yeah I want to um I want to
say a lot more like this picture came
out on Twitter of this um like uh six
chains operation it was a penis yeah it
looked like it stitches it looked like a
Louis Vuitton bag yes and we want to
talk about that on YouTube but I'm sure
they would have hit us with a strike
right yes because it's nudity even
though it's just patent leather right
yeah
okay so that you just so no it's fake
yeah you couldn't even go with top grain
leather no yeah a nice Goodyear welt so
but you guys are going to talk about
that your first show is going to be what
Thursday the 5th I believe in October
yeah we're going in detail on that yeah
because also you have problems that you
have to sensor with patreon all that so
all that will be migrating Under the
Umbrella world you know everything yeah
so you'll still get it you'll get kind
of like what we do where you get a
portion for for free and then a portion
in Mud Club right so you can you'll get
that with them as well so I'm looking
forward so stay posted because no we're
not tuned stay tuned stay keep we'll
keep you posted you stay tuned keep
block perfect name that reference but uh
it's one of those we're never looking to
take away freak always more free content
plus even more for those of you who are
members at the Mud Club lottoscutter.com
none of this happens there is no free
content if you don't join the fight and
we have the investigative journalism
unit doing a lot too all right um first
story of the day it's a pick-me-up this
Algerian migrant this went viral
yesterday I guess
in Sweden and here's the thing before we
show this clip there there seem to be
multiple points you know people use the
term de-escalate and by that I mean you
could by killing said uh migrant here
who's trying to kill his ex-girlfriend
in Sweden and he actually gets close
there you go okay
[Music]
so he's telling him that he's coming up
there to kill his ex-girlfriend
crazy well he's holding his hand out
like it's a tiger shark
push the ladder
kick him in the face
why are you got a knife
dude
yeah now see here's the thing if you
have a gun that's a non-issue firearm
that's why I'm a pro-second Amendment
because I don't believe that men like
that should be uh wasting oxygen who
would prefer that he assume room
temperature the guy stabbed his Swedish
ex-girlfriend's male friend then at that
point with a large kitchen knife in the
neck yeah and by the way owing for the
kill it's not like it was concealed
he grabbed the Michael Myers now hey
guys definitely liberal
push the and do it slowly so he has time
to think about his mistake
do it again
yeah until he learned crying out loud I
hope he falls on that knife though yeah
oh that's right yeah well he would fall
on that knife in my hand yeah yes and
the guy by the way jailed for two years
that
she is that's it attempted murder yeah
and by the way he also said that he
would quote open up the victim and rape
her mother this was a horrible horrible
person this is why pacifism but hey if
you're not willing to fight for the
woman who's there in that apartment or
maybe she had escaped at that point if
you're not willing to to to kill to
protect your own life just and by the
way at this point you know you don't
need to kill him you just push the
ladder over and the death is incidental
yeah it's accident
Russ people see that as progress no no
but some people on the left do it's like
can't we solve this through non-violent
means now picture that only picture
psychotherapists and social workers
going out instead of police officers now
you have defund the police no exactly
now that guy's eating through a straw
for the rest of his life because he's
like no man don't don't break the window
you didn't even get a knife he kept
recording I'm like you're doing this for
social media clouds you clearly have a
free hand down he chose to film it I
know I see that large knife they'll know
you're on camera you're on camera I'm
going to show the police show them good
luck good luck calling them and having
them arrive before I stab you in neck no
you don't step a neck I stab a neck oh
no it's Mr stabbing Nickerson I didn't
recognize
play it again and just see the different
let's just see the different entry
points where you could eliminate this
man uh here in the United States all
right let's watch I guess okay so right
away you don't know you know maybe he's
doing some Roofing now he's making the
threat okay throw something down or at
least you know shoot him you could just
drop a heavy knife
he'll leave grab him by his receding
hair throw him down kick him in the face
push him down there yeah kick him in the
face
come up
now bang bang bang bang bang fan the
hammer
man this is why we've done those
campaigns horror movies wouldn't be
horror film without it he had the
advantage I know
man he had literally The Higher Ground
yeah yeah he had the only ground yeah he
let himself get stabbed
in the neck
it's a miracle that he's alive and this
is why when people say you want a
violent gun culture no no I want a
culture where there are far more
headlines that read would-be rapist yes
would be murderer uh killed by a woman
with firearm because that by the way
could just as easily in that video be a
woman who's completely defenseless
that's who he was after yeah
people say oh it's a Trope the only
thing that stops a bad guy with a gun is
a good guy with a gun okay you know I'll
give you that the only thing that stops
a bad Algerian migrant with a knife is
anyone with a gun that's true even your
gay friend who can't protect you while
recording oh especially gay friends with
these migrants I mean she needs a if
this guy had his way to be reigning men
in Sweden for about a week all right
it's a live show by the way Monday
through Friday 10 a.m Eastern here on
Rumble you can be watching on YouTube of
course The Hodgetwins just said they
sometimes self-censor so we do have the
YouTube dump button if you're watching
on YouTube and you at any point see this
foreign
[Music]
like five seconds of that music it's
nice yeah and then go yeah and then go
it's soothing it is yeah especially if
you have a man climbing a ladder up to
your balcony to murder you and your
family yes yeah I'm watching ladder with
Crowder good Lord do I hate Europe all
right
but hey we're not without our flaws here
in the United States fair right which
brings us to Burning Man so
[Laughter]
because they burn a man well not a real
one they burn it yeah an effigy well oh
yeah they burn a man that's a stupid
look look and by the if you like Bernie
I get it if people want to go and have
fun I don't care okay but uh this year's
Burning Man festival kind of ended on a
on a sour wet note after these
torrential rain pours swept it's Black
Rock I think Black Rock City the desert
in Nevada and it's almost like God's
flood washing away the modern equivalent
of filthy hippies but uh there's a
little more to it here's a here's a clip
after
more than 70
the remote Nevada
driving a vehicle right now is
impossible there is absolutely because
you have no peripheral vision with your
wrestling costume video of people who
came for the normally sun-soaked Burning
Man festival but Extreme weather
intervened uh this video taken just a
short time ago as the revelers were
making their way out of the Black Rock
Desert in Nevada
foreign
how does it get that deep
it's like he had to deal with a
superhero like mutton man just
you'll never get out of this shitty
desert
especially because you're on E now
no laughing matter one death was
reported that's sad that's obviously
it's it's terrible
um and uh and The Exodus from the desert
uh began yesterday where everyone is now
leaving uh the desert and um what sucks
because they they missed the grand
finale
ah
why people drive out for that yeah it
doesn't make any sense it seems illegal
yeah by the way did they bring up a
mission control there are these like
shrimp growing there in the mud in the
desert that come up from the city yeah
it's like these they look like shrimp
but they're not these little hatchlings
someone can send them in in the chat
right now or they're growing yeah it
could just be it could just be you know
it could just be falling crabs and then
they just I have no idea what there are
bugs growing
so here's the thing burning man I got
the hot bathroom
it's Guided by desert shrimp Salt Flat
shrimp soft flat hatchlings bananas
Burning Man is Guided by 10 principles
you ask me what is Burning Man which is
by the way a very it's a very black
question asked it's less than one
percent of attendees are black people
yeah I could see why yeah
because I think black people aren't into
you know like doing the whole camping
thing because enough of them are already
homeless
oh
people that's and Veterans unfair no
no camping no I know is that people like
Glam why would they want to act like a
homeless person for the weekend
yes exactly here's the shrimp we got we
got the shrimp bring it up good bring it
up
oh what yeah it gets out of that skin
that's not a shrimp that's something I'm
just calling it desert shrimp it's
science is that real that's real it's
the chicken of the Burning Man Salt
Flats that's real yes it's Mana from
Heaven Too yes exactly hold it that
whole area was on the water once oh my
God why are you throwing this up
what the hell is that that's what's
growing out of the the mud it looks like
that movie Life where that thing was so
small yeah look we found life and killed
everybody yeah that is so weird because
that's just like a desert as soon as
yeah all that was underwater it's like
yeah because of mud I think they
probably live and then I don't know what
happens to the water but Burning Man is
Guided by 10 principles which is kind of
funny including radical inclusion
decommodification leaving no trace and
by the way self-reliance though it's
pretty tough to do once there's a slight
drizzle and I get it it's not it's look
obviously these people should have fun
but here's the thing Elon Musk did say
that Burning Man is Silicon Valley
Silicon Valley is Burning Man because
they want to act like they're going out
in this Bohemian atmosphere of artists
and the tickets are like 575 dollars per
person 140 dollars per vehicle but there
are 5 000 low-income tickets offered at
225 dollars I'm one of those low-income
people yes you have a special badge you
have to wear well here's the thing when
it's based on this inclusion and utopian
ideals and Community
why were they so unprepared you know you
can comment below either there's a
windstorm every year or occasionally you
get rain but it's kind of prepare for
one of the two did you see the ones
where they were the fire tornadoes yes
basically that wasn't this year I think
it was last year or something like that
I was like how do you not see this as a
sign from God yeah I hire tornadoes now
a flood what firstborn is that next what
do we do here yeah I half expected Howie
Long to show up
firestorm
everybody kind of chuckled like remember
that movie Firestorm Howie Long yeah
yeah it was terrible it was his only
action movie ever like hey your buff and
you can oh no you can't act now ah by
the way before we move on that last
principle leave no Trace how does that
work with dead bodies yeah I just want
to know what your policy is yeah well
it's you know it goes back to the Earth
it's biodegradable yes recycling that's
where I'd love to dump my Algerian
migrants that's where that's where it
was just some specific knife wielding
yeah exactly I mean I wouldn't leave the
ladder you know I respect Mother Earth
yeah that won't recycle speaking of
which let's go into Elon Musk here so I
do have a question for you uh do you
think that Elon Musk is what percentage
put a percentage on it as far as good
based you know uh Freedom loving versus
bad maybe still kind of maintaining some
bad Tendencies or habits from before I
think he's a mix so we're going to do a
segment here right now good Elon bad
Elon now I'm glad that he took over
Twitter yeah not necessarily thrilled
with uh the people who are running
Twitter who aren't necessarily him
so let me first set this up with this
clip uh the ADLs but the Anti-Defamation
League by the way I'm just going to say
ADL here today the ADL spokesperson uh
Jonathan Greenblatt he was uh sort of I
guess you should say brow beating
Twitter calling them out for allowing
the spread of quote uh hate on his
platform here is the uh lesser uh Xavier
brother but this is Linda yaccarino the
new CEO of X formerly Twitter just eight
hours ago posting the following she says
and platform safety odds
is that true possible it's that
certainly seems to contradict what we're
seeing on almost all of these Services
now look they announced their reorg at X
yesterday and now Linda is in charge of
trust and safety that's a good thing
because she understood how to handle
these issues I believe at NBC Universal
but the truth is is that what we're
seeing on Twitter X today is really
alarming really it's alarming the Lesser
Xavier that's the style that he's going
with too he really is trying to go for
the Charles Xavier just rolling in
yeah
I'm sensing white men on a platform
this must end thanks chip I've never
seen any hate on Twitter not one really
once nope oh wow it look it's part of
and I don't by the way that's why we say
it's a live show Monday through Thursday
today and we make all the references
available I am telling you I think that
social media just like like porn today
in the digital is horrible for your
brain I don't like the scrolling
algorithm culture where everything is 10
seconds that's not good for kids just to
be clear we used to sit down and watch
television at a certain time and they
would say TV would rot your brain turns
out that wasn't the case TV actually
expanded imagination certainly films but
you would sit down set a time and pay
attention now people are watching
television while they're on their phone
scrolling for something more interesting
and it's never as interesting as you
hope that it will be and so you need a
new app because Facebook wasn't enough
and so you need Twitter and then you
need Instagram and then you need tick
tock and then you need Snapchat we
literally whittled it down people like
nah YouTube won't work and uh and uh and
Twitter with the videos now 140
characters no we need four seconds for
tick tock
and I get that that's a gross
exaggeration but actually not it's a
slight exactly close yeah pretty good
like a Vine so let's get into X sorry
Twitter I'm going to misspeak on that
here's good Elon okay
we didn't preview that one um so this
weekend Elon Musk he did he went on a
crusade against the ADL the
Anti-Defamation League for killing
Twitter's ad Revenue here are some of
the tweets where he said since the
acquisition the ADL has been trying to
kill this platform by falsely accusing
it and me of being anti-semitic our U.S
advertising revenue is still down 60
primarily due to pressure on advertisers
by the ADL uh that's what the
advertisers tell us so they almost
succeeded in killing X or Twitter and
just to be clear I can tell you this
from first-hand experience that is
absolutely true so when people say oh
you're free to say whatever you it's not
a violation of the First Amendment if
the government isn't doing it well first
off that brings us to section 230 and
these companies receive massive tax
breaks and outright subsidies from the
government but even worse than that is
when you have cancel culture is not just
about someone saying something and
people being offended it's about people
in power like the ADL or like the
companies that advertise on YouTube and
Google by the way largely ABC Disney
yeah that's right and ABC Disney NBC
Universal I get them always confusers
Comcast Time Warner so they get to
dictate what is permissible and what is
not when people get together and declare
what you say offensive so they get to
shut off the advertising Revenue even
though the audience doesn't find it
offensive
that's when you have effectively what is
a big Tech oligarchy in bed with the
government and that's why we've done mug
club we we don't make a dime off of
YouTube to be clear off of the Google
advertising on these videos it's
entirely funded by viewers like you and
a couple of sponsors because it's not
about people being offended it's about
advertisers putting pressure so that
they can remove what they don't like
Tucker Carlson should have been making
the most amount of Revenue on Fox News
humanly possible he wasn't not because
of the audience but because of the
advertisers and ESG and BlackRock and
Vanguard that's it's not Market forces
when it's beholden to international
governing body yeah and that's one of
the things that Elon got right early on
he said we have to go away from this
advertiser-centric model because if you
do stay with that model you're always
going to be beholden to advertisers and
so right it is the government's a big
enough Problem by itself probably the
biggest problem right there though is
advertisers getting together and
basically saying hey we're just going to
remove money yeah go create your own
thing fantastic nobody is going to
advertise on it that none of the big
players at least right you're gonna have
to go and get all these other people
that's why you have to move away from
that that's why Mud Club exists right
well I can tell you a lot of
conservative companies aren't allowed to
advertise at all I know they're just
barred from it I've been on both sides
where we at one point made revenue on
YouTube and then I also try to advertise
and they said no well wait a second I'd
like to advertise on these conservative
channels that you are telling you're
telling them that no advertisers want to
advertise I say yeah but we can't
actually do that kind of targeting for
you I go oh okay but you can do drag
queen Story Hour on Ben Shapiro's
YouTube channel
I'm just saying that whatever they're
never matched up properly wasn't Ben's
fault but still no of course there's
nothing I'm just saying that they allow
if you allow liberal companies leftist
companies International conglomerates
you allow them to advertise and you
don't allow the right-leaning mom and
pop well then all of a sudden you can
say there's no Revenue in conservative
content and right it's not true there
are more of you than them there are just
more of them in positions of power and
it's really easy to grease those Palms
when you work for government by the way
that includes Republicans because they
want to be permanent uh permanent hires
are in the government so Elon by the way
even threatened to sue uh the ADL he
said if this continues
is this Elon saying that I can't quite
hear you want me to do that I just I I
don't know it doesn't sound like Elon I
don't really so if this uh continues we
will have no choice but to file a
defamation suit ironically uh against
the Anti-Defamation League
and if they lose the defamation suit we
will insist that they drop the empty
part of their name since uh obviously
well I don't think it's obvious but
yeah and is he doing this I know you
might say for the Jews because according
by the way to must the ADL even
specifically push to shut down accounts
like Libs of tick tock of course Haya
runs that over there
um and is of the Jewish persuasion I
don't know how to say it where it
doesn't sound it feels like Jews sounds
anti-semitic even though it's like but
she's a Jew but I mean she's Jewish
she's she is Jewish she's very she's
very open about being Jewish and I think
they're banning her because she's she's
she's a Jew
let's just go with yuden we admit it in
a good way so Elon even agreed that uh
that lives of uh with uh lives of tick
tock that releasing Communications
between X Twitter and the ADL would be
in the public interest at this point hey
we need to know what's going on
right he said great point a giant data
dump would clear the air well just do it
then just do it and here's the thing you
guys need if you don't know about the
ADL there's a Southern Property Law
Center the ADL and they determine
everything on big Tech as far as what is
there's there's Community guidelines
there's Advertiser friendly guidelines
and then there's borderline content
guidelines and this is when we were
always on the phone with someone at your
fault that was my fault they created it
because of me after the Vox apocalypse I
apologize you could admonish me Tim I
didn't mean to I didn't mean to but they
said we didn't violate Community
guidelines and I said that's fine you
don't have to we don't expect to make
money anyways we're going to create new
borderline uh guidelines and then we're
going to became a game of cat and mouse
but now we're on Rumble we don't care so
a big part of what determines that is
Southern Poverty Law Center ADL these
organizations who by the way file large
Evangelical Christian churches as hate
groups yeah just to be clear as to how
extreme they are and the ADL themselves
they they change their definition of
racism which I didn't know you could
just change definitions unfortunately
it's happened a lot the last five years
yeah yeah it's science they changed it
specifically after the George Floyd
incident so this is pre-july 2020. they
describe racism as the belief that a
that a particular race is Superior or
inferior to another and that people's
social and moral traits are
predetermined by inborn biological
characteristics well that makes sense
that is racist to believe that you are
better than someone else just because
they're born black right I think we all
agree that's or born White and by the
way it's not racist to say that if you
look at me Keith and Kevin I'm likely
slower
[Laughter]
she's out there whoa no well not not if
we're in a pool yeah now
it's absolutely true you it's the build
of the Cavs and the thing yeah
like many chaos too you know
see I don't know how that yeah you got
white man swimming ability yeah I got
the black man swimming swim like rocks I
just found out Steve help
I found out this weekend that I couldn't
float when I was swimming with the
little ones I was like man I sent to my
dad I said I'm really really bad at
Treading Water I used to be a great
swimmer and he goes well take a big deep
breath and you know just hold the breath
and take shallow breath I took a big
deep breath and then I sunk so quickly
that my foot made an impact I realized I
have a bunch of metal in my body oh yeah
yeah I completely forgot you forget that
put a couple pounds of titanium in your
pocket and I was like oh okay so I was
very hungry so this was a definition
again pre-july 2020 the belief that
particular race is Superior or inferior
to another and that people's social
Memorial traits are predetermined by
inborn biological characteristics now
after George Floyd they switched the
definition of racism the adl-2 the
marginalization and or oppression of
people of color based on a socially
constructed racial hierarchy that
privileges white people oh there it is
ah why does he make sense
it's funny too that they said that that
a socially constructed racial hierarchy
that privileges white people after we
had a black president like yeah it would
have made more sense if they changed it
the other way after Barack Obama yeah
this is a social construct won't they
just abolish race yes if they want to go
against races and that definition is so
ambiguous it doesn't make sense right it
could mean anything and it just assumes
that it privileges white people and I
don't know we'll get into that segment a
little later um white to it we die at
work and if we don't we kill ourselves
in record numbers white males it's not
even close not even close sounds like a
sounds like a lot of privilege hey you
guys getting a lot of alimony you too
okay
oh privilege by the way smash the rumble
button uh here while you're watching
because it uh I don't really know if we
need people to smash the rumble button
it's a like button on Rumble now right
well it's it's a thumbs up okay it's a
thumbs up yeah here it is
he just wants to keep the original
because it feels like an after-school
special oh
well not yours Yakuza yours would be to
take drugs no yeah well so that was good
Elon fighting back with ADL but let's go
to bad Elon
um and there's good and bad again
is that a wild boar sounds like yeah I
guess is that the World of Warcraft
so everyone has good and bad but I've
said this before like when Kanye came
out his gospel album I said look I'm
really glad that he seems to be but
don't give him more of a platform than
he's able to handle and I think that
Elon is a little bit yeah and he kind of
you know he kind of went a little too yo
next going so he took too far
although it was the most fun week I love
Hitler no no no he's quoting yeah it's
irony right you're doing this as
performance like no I
oh Lord I'm getting canceled I'm
definitely not getting back on Twitter
that's so funny he made Alex Jones
feeling coach I know it's hard to do
which is hard to do yeah yes they were
treating Kanye West the way that we all
treat Alex Jones on our shows
uh Elon right his ex also announced at
this exact same time good that they're
fighting back on the ADL um
but they're also going to be collecting
users biometric data fully X formerly
known as Twitter is going to collect my
biometric data
how how are they going to do that so
I've spoken to X this morning and this
is what the company told me first of all
this is only applicable to premium users
those that pay the subscription what
they're going to offer you the chance to
do is submit a government issued ID with
a selfie a picture that will be used for
two-stage verification I hate everything
about that phrase ID where the biometric
data will be extracted from is it
considered domestic terrorism if I send
the government just a stool sample
allegedly
everything about that phrase you need to
send the government-issued ID for
two-point biometric authentication
process everything about that is
terrifying yes yeah what's the purpose
though it's two-step authentication it's
just to make sure your account is secure
yes it's for your so they'll collect
things for my protection yes yes oh okay
yes fingerprint data Iris scans they'll
also collect things like education
history work history because and here's
the problem right let's say that Elon
Musk and this is my issue here is I
think that he wants to do the right
thing right I think he's a little bit
immature someone in his political uh
beliefs in his Persuasions but I think
that he's developing nicely and I do
think that he he Champions freedom I do
think he genuinely cares about free
speech
um so I generally like him but this
could very easily and most likely will
change hands at some point right he's
probably not going to be the primary uh
owner of of Twitter in the future and
now they've collected your fingerprints
they've collected your iris uh data
they've collected your education history
your work history and someone else comes
in let's say like a Jack Dorsey I mean
we've seen stranger things right Dave
portney sold his company bar stool for I
think 500 million got it back for a
dollar these entities change hands it
just takes falling in the wrong hands
once and oh by the way we also know that
the FBI is communicated with Twitter in
the past we also know that of course not
carrying Jean-Pierre but uh saki at one
point was calling on Twitter to ban
conservatives you make it that much
easier when you have basically our DNA
samples
and that is a scary thought and do you
think the good outweighs the bad by the
way this is right in line with what Elon
said he spoke about this I think we have
a clip where he wanted to make X Twitter
it's hard to say in a sentence yeah he
wanted to make it the American version
of WeChat we don't even have a a a an
app that's as good as WeChat in China uh
and like in China you can like live on
WeChat basically yeah
when we chat you do payments you do
everything it's like yup it's great okay
sweet checks Kick-Ass um and we don't
have anything like WeChat outside of
China
so good it's like my idea would be like
how about if we just copy WeChat yeah
hold on a sec we also don't have like a
social credit score system that
resembles Black Mirror so that's what I
don't see enough of from Elon the the
the the the challenging of China and I
think that's because it's a huge it's a
huge market for them it's important for
me wants it to be like WeChat we'll do a
whole other segment on WeChat I do not
want us to be like WeChat my general
rule is if crazy communist China is
doing it one way that we should consider
the other direction
at least for a minute yeah I mean how is
it how is it not possible for him to see
that because you know he knows about the
issues that they've faced in China with
WeChat and being able to Bar people from
travel and being able to make sure they
can't get loans or bank accounts or have
to distance from friends because they
have bad ideas and that's going to lower
your credit score socially like how does
he not know all of that exists and say
hey we want all of the good things of
WeChat and none of the bad so we're not
going to collect all that data yeah it's
based on the bad things though it that's
the problem it's based on the bad thing
at least with X you have to pay for the
privilege of them Gathering all that
information
so that's good yeah no you kind of
deserve it it's simple yeah I guess we
do yeah crap kind of like if you don't
tip the ladder of the Algerian migrants
I'm coming to kill you it's on you at a
certain point yeah once he punches you
in the face you're like well I deserve
it he did say he was going to stab me
and you know I held my hand out like I
was a like I had psychic powers like I
was a gene gray and instead he just
stabbed the straight through my hand and
yeah uh now I'm uh now I remember at
this
so let's be like WeChat yeah let's
follow you want to follow China's lead
let's do it uh when covet inevitably
spikes again
that's nuts but it's effective
what's going on locking them in their
apartment yeah
that's a poorly constructed door yes it
is
[Applause]
screams for Joy nope
well we'll start with the Democrats if
we do that now
thing though when people talk about you
know with right now there are some very
Asian neighborhoods around here like
entirely yeah Chinese neighborhoods
entirely Indian neighborhoods I see
people all the time right now driving
with face Shields Asian Americans face
shields in their own car this is
something that needs to happen
by themselves and I will say this and
you can comment I don't care if you say
this is racist I don't give a ratsest
they come from a country meaning places
like China and by the way even places
like South Korea where uh control from
the government is fine right
subservience to the government is a part
of how it works right and it's a culture
of fear that needs to take place if
you're going to come to this country
there needs to be some some portion
that's taught not only with your oath
not only with Civics but hey and by the
way we don't give up our freedoms here
no we do not give up our freedoms in the
name of security people who will wear a
face shield alone in the car that is not
by the way that is not someone following
the science at all at all fauci even
said that the data was murky on masks by
the way in crowded spaces face Shields
alone in your your own car no no the
science is in that is because this is a
culture that starts from the basis of
fear and subservience to the government
and it's not their fault it's drilled
into them from a very very young age for
example in places like China and also
the same thing in Japan in a lot of ways
yeah just to be clear that's why you can
have no guns and you don't have the same
rates of crime because people are people
are terrified of their government their
government is Daddy they control so many
aspects of life because it's been given
up a very long time ago this is the only
country left where that isn't the case
and if we are going to be bringing in
people from other countries they need to
understand it is foundational to this
country you're driving alone with a face
shield you should be deported yes
goodbye I said yes far too quickly on
that I didn't know where you're going to
stick the landing yeah no in South Korea
you're just trained not to question
authority and case in point I think it
was in the 80s or early 90s you can fact
check me on it a South Korean Airline
flew into the ground because they ran
out of fuel and they didn't challenge
the air traffic controller I believe is
that one of the New York airports I
can't remember LaGuardia or the other
one JFK literally they're like hey did
you tell them we're running out of field
he's like yeah I told him we're running
out of field he's like well okay I guess
we're just gonna crash and die instead
of just like that's the kind of cultural
mindset and you have to have the mindset
of if we don't protect our freedoms they
will eventually be taken by someone
whether that's the government or
corporate or somebody else it will be
taken eventually by your neighbor you
have to protect your freedom and
question authority that's fine you don't
have to be belligerent towards Authority
you just have to question yeah well here
we would have been accountable some some
pilot or whatever I don't know a Tarmac
technician from Jersey it's spirited
like hey you dumb you forgot to put gas
in it hey we're about to run he's
literally said he goes they were talking
about it and the the end result was it
was like the guy that jumped the Korean
yeah the Jersey guy that was the air
traffic controller was too Brusque with
them wait what are you talking about
this the guy communicating with the
plane that crashed was so Brusque with
them like he was just like so dismissive
of them they were like well yeah I told
him but he was me yeah so I noticed like
what but a woman was in Austria about 10
12 years ago yeah before called even
yeah and we was we there's a lot of
Asian people that I was like wow these
people wearing masks
right in Australia oh okay yeah
Australia well they wear masks is part
of the culture right because the you
know the smog and everything we've
talked about that with the Olympics in
China and some of the athletes in the US
got booted off the team for wearing
black masks when they got off the plane
because the smog was so bad or they were
they were skiing down a nuclear power
plant that's true
that's also true they actually did their
skiing down call no no no no no ignore
all three eye fish just ski skis you'll
be fine Bottom now nuclear reactor we
keep it warm we already run study very
safe
ignore her nipple
by the way before we get into this next
segment we actually have a clip on how
you're supposed to deal with a migrant
who climbs a ladder okay let's see yeah
that's essentially the same well yeah
instructional that they're watching
no yeah no yeah I think it would have
been happier I wondering if he was shot
all right yeah
hit the like button if you agree hey
that's me Mr old-fashioned
people are afraid because they're afraid
of being censored on YouTube Hey Hey
someone's climbing up a ladder to stab
you and or your wife or girlfriend
the best outcome is shooting him yeah it
would just shut him if he was white oh
that's fair no it's Sweden they don't I
don't think they don't have guns right
they don't have guns they don't have
guns and Suites it's very limited yeah I
mean they have guns but they don't have
like a Second Amendment right it's not
the same thing as as here people are I
mean you can be arrested in the UK If
you act even with a hunting rifle If you
defend your house you will be the one
who was arrested I'm sorry when people
say you have a gun culture in the United
States well I prefer that to that
culture because you know what at least a
gun culture and by the way the murders
the the homicides when you when you take
away the gun deaths you take away the
suicides which we'll get into when you
take away the inter-gang related crime
your chances of being killed as uh you
know a victim of gun violence a homicide
are so tiny now don't forget the
minorities
inner urban yeah Gang Related crime like
you know when they say oh guns are the
number one killer of children no it's
black
no take away 15 to 19 year olds who are
black boys and gangs yeah it's not it's
not even close when you're talking about
the ages 0 through 12 it's drowning it's
basic access automobile accidents and
the disservice that this does is it
scares you into changing the wrong thing
look that culture in Sweden it only gets
worse it only gets worse we kind of have
a cap here in the United States as to
how bad it gets as to how many migrants
can rape people on mass we're not going
to have what happened in Cologne New
Year's Eve party yeah exactly I would
rather have a gun culture where you
shoot that man trying who not try he did
stab the the homeowner or renter I'd
rather have that culture than
defenseless innocent citizens why
because I don't think all violence is
equivalent violence is amoral I can use
this knife to stab a man as I parkour up
his apartment complex or I can use my
gun to stop a man from raping my my wife
yeah violence is not all that's why I
have a problem with uh Zero Tolerance
policies in school it sends the wrong
message all right and this brings us
while we're talking about violence this
is something that is but we've talked
about this quite a bit we've talked
about it on the show and kind of touched
on this but we haven't really done one
segment uh that is all inclusive and uh
I think this is something that's pretty
important because like I talked about
earlier in the show we often discuss the
idea of people getting help of not
stigmatizing mental health issues of
dealing with suicide in this problem of
deal suicide sorry the suicide problem
in this country of dealing with
isolation especially after covid
but then we also have the media brow
beating the people namely white men who
make up that statistic it's not even
close so let me set this up for you I'm
not talking about that that 92 percent
of all workplace workplace workplace
Mike Tyson 92 of all works like 92 of
all workplace deaths are men okay that's
man of all different races you know that
so when people talk about male privilege
all right sweetheart go work in a
Foundry now
when it comes to suicide in the United
States
middle-aged white men are Far and Away
the largest demographic if you're going
to solve the problem of suicide in this
country
if you are serious about tackling it
you need to tackle the issue of white
men and they're totally ignored and I
tell you what we exacerbate the problem
in this country all the feminists right
now who get matters say oh poor you as a
white man yeah yeah just just be a
little open-minded here because the
numbers are irrefutable women you're so
oppressed that you do not commit suicide
black men it's not even close black
women it's not even close why oh why are
white men specifically middle-aged white
men committing suicide at astronomical
rates
suicide is the 12th leading cause of
death in the United States and the
highest rate of suicide is in
middle-aged white men in 2020 69 of
Americans who died by Suicide were white
men yeah so let me give you a couple of
of brief statistics so in the United
States um suicides total were forty nine
thousand okay in 2022. white men 68 of
that
okay and I think they make up somewhere
between 20 something and 30 something
percent of the population so more than
double their percentage of the
population white males four times more
likely to commit suicide than white
females white males nine times more
likely to commit suicide than black
Americans
just to be clear which brings me to
another key fact here fact number two
um I think there are a few reasons for
this strike straight white men are often
ignored
just to be clear so those facts exist
all the references are available at live
with credit.com now let's say why and is
there something that we can do about
this and this is the problem right when
people the the the the
patronizing right the the sarcasm that
takes place the oh poor baby you've had
it hard as a straight white man do you
know how do you have any idea what it's
like and then insert whatever oppression
that day that you got you got passed
over for a promotion or that you have to
you have to choose between being a
stay-at-home mom versus a career well it
must be nice to have a choice that's a
big reason
straight women don't really have a
choice they have to work if they want to
if they want to find a wife period they
don't get to be a stay-at-home dad so
straight white men are often ignored so
let me give you some examples here the
US government the suicide lifeline
they list very specific resources uh
regarding suicide
for every group except white males wow
every group except white males
ridiculous oh poor baby yeah poor bit
it's the suicide stat there's no getting
away from let's look at Google Trends
women suicide and LGBT suicide they
Trend far far higher than white male
suicide here's another one we have
another graph Google engram Trends okay
female suicide has been written about to
an incredible yeah there you go look at
that spread compared to white male
suicide so the writing and the resources
are all directed towards a a statistical
group women who are four times less
likely to commit suicide and by the way
when they attempt suicide signifi they
don't attempt that they don't succeed
right because men finish the job oh yeah
women can't do nothing right into that
God but in other words all of these
resources are made available why because
of the oppression Olympics that's it's
women it's black people it's stop Asian
hate well hold on a second you want to
deal with suicide it's not even close
the trend goes all the way back by the
way to the 19th century and um as far as
how it
manifests itself in dealing with largely
straight white men I think we all know
how the left thinks
[Laughter]
that's rude it's very rude
you call the suicide hotline and you
hear that
um and I was going through this myself
going what are the reasons well um there
are a few different reasons let's go to
another key fact number three and you
guys can I know this is very white male
Centric but you guys can obviously jump
in yeah yeah um white men stay silent
tell me about tell me about white people
yes well here's the one thing I will say
there's a lot of Shame uh in the
community people always talk about Shane
like you know you shouldn't be ashamed
of anything we need to do away with
shame usually that means there's a fat
broad with a hip-hop video or it means
that there's some girl who slept with
half the Oakland Raiders and doesn't
want to be slut-shamed guess what white
man we're shame no matter what
that's a fact what white men accept the
shame and by the way so that
comfortable this kind of shocked me I
knew that white men would uh be less
likely to seek therapy than let's say
white women but whites in general are
less likely to speak to health
professionals about mental illness
compared with black Americans or Latinos
and white men are far less likely to
seek any kind of mental health
assistance uh when compared to women and
I can imagine why because it's oh yeah
you have such a you have such a hard
time Mr patriarchy again look at the
people who go into psychology right it's
basically feminism run amok that's how
you end up with the DSM-5 switching
gender dysphoria from a dis from a
disorder to the symptoms of being born
in a wrong body men white men often feel
like failures the reason they feel like
failures is because they're very high
societal expectations they want to be
providers
right and if they don't provide or they
get laid off that's a huge contributing
factor
to people uh committing suicide that's
what I was thinking if if you're a white
man which I'm not if you have it's okay
consider you you are deemed to if you're
not successful you're a total failure
right twice as yeah they're twice to
failure yeah it really is and and we
you're not going to change that what man
in general especially decent men they
want to provide right we want to provide
we want to keep our families safe
but things happen sometimes you get some
tough breaks yeah yeah and then there's
there's staggeringly few resources
available that cater to white men now
look we're not laying the victim card on
ourselves here what we're saying is if
you're really looking to fix this
problem you've got to focus on the group
that accounts for almost 70 percent of
the problem yes right and not completely
leave them out so white man gets fired
and he's 51 years old what are the
resources for that of course you're
going to feel helpless we have resources
to get him fired that's the point we
have Resources with affirmative action
or with diversity quotas we have
resources to ensure that white men lose
their just to be clear this is a
statistical reality I'm not saying that
white men have it harder than every or
any other group I am saying that white
men off themselves
to a number that is alarming and
irrefutable and what do we left to say
they say well white men just can't cope
in current Society your time's up so
would have left us really think what is
it you want us to do
[Music]
this is what I'm saying there's no
talking with these at least it's honest
I mean the good news is that one of the
resources is a strong support network of
friends is very important and can help a
tremendous amount now my fingers on the
trigger don't try to stop miss me oh not
again this is it don't try to stop me
this times me don't try to stop me this
times me don't you dare try to stop me
this time Smee try to stop me it's me
you better get up off your ass hey I'm
coming I'm coming this is not a joke
so so confusing and you know what hey do
me a favor um if you think this is an
issue that needs to be discussed more
hit the like button comment below if
you've been affected by Suicide
um because a lot of the hotlines that
exist actually uh don't actually exist
to help support
white males and we'll get to that in a
second and I hate pulling identity
politics here but the reason that it
matters is because white men are often
singled out look there are a lot of
issues that contribute to the higher
likelihood of suicide losing your job is
one of them okay uh being divorced is
one of them when up to 80 percent of
divorces are currently filed by women in
domestic abuse or infidelity are not
even the top five reasons listed if it's
about 80 if it's a college degree it's
about 68 if there isn't so divorce
increases it if you're abandoned losing
your job increases it not having a
strong circle of friends well for the
same reason that men make up 92 of
workplace deaths huge part of men's
Social Circle and their friends
are their work colleagues that's a big
way that men find purpose so you can
lose all of it right this is not an
atypical story man loses his job he now
loses touch with his friends he can't
provide and his woman leaves them
it's not like that doesn't happen all
the time that man is hanging by a thread
and if you know that person please reach
out and help them this brings us to
another key fact number four
um and this is the anti-white male
culture that we deal with in media so
you have the mainstream media of course
they're always praising single moms
right it's the single moms let it hears
from Huffington Post these are some
headlines here let us now pray single
moms and there's another one single moms
need to praise themselves here's why and
here's seven damn good reasons to date a
single mom hey you ever get an article
like that as a man like hey hey you
black twins need to praise themselves
here's why
seven damn good reasons to date a man
who doesn't pay alimony like this is
don't get the passes and specifically
white men do not get the free passes
that women do Joe Rogan made this point
on body positivity but we'll get into it
a little more you know who doesn't get
any of that uh body positivity though is
men
nobody gives a about men if a
matter of fact you're just fat and
here's a recent article from um what is
this what is the afru just to be clear
through after I forget what the acronym
is for it says body positivity
is for women not lazy white guys with
Dad Bots okay just to be clear also the
term dadpod has expanded dramatically it
means any man who does not have a
reptilian six-pack like an Instagram
influencer right like oh you have 12
body fat dad bod your lizzo
is there a mombod hey look let me give
you an example you're beautiful no
matter what size you are to women do men
get that hey where is the where is the
fat Pride male model and by the way we
don't want one we don't just to be clear
you know what we say to our fat friend
we're like hey chubby over here he's
probably nicknamed chubby yeah no doubt
what's that no no guy wants that because
we know that women don't want that right
and we don't get to lie and declare
ourselves beautiful and we don't have
Society declaring us beautiful I had one
woman say well it's okay for men to be
fat not for women I said okay give me
some examples well you know there are
plenty of successful fat men I go right
but who's equivalent to a test holiday
or like a lizzo or what's happened with
swimsuit uh Sports Illustrated I guess
the swimsuit edition
she said well think about people like
you know you have Chris Farley you could
have Jonah Hill you could have John
Candy I go those people are some of the
most talented men on Earth and they're
not sex symbols they're popular because
they're funny yeah they're popular
because they're talented they're not
praise for being beautiful that's the
difference women are praised no matter
what they do and men are often shamed no
matter what they do particularly white
males this is a fact and even if you
don't agree with all the other facts
being presented here all references are
available there is no getting around the
suicide statistic body positivity this
quote is for women not lazy white guys
with Dad bods this person specifically
wrote white guys and never really hear
about black guys having Dad but because
they have access to weights in the
prison yard
foreign
[Music]
hey this guy's in here for murder he
gets out in 15. what do you think we
should do I don't know is there any way
for us to make him more athletic
wow it's kind of a squat rack
I mean get him like some make some
bracelets right calm them down don't
give them iron to pump that crochet yeah
but then you have the needles
so here's some more headlines here's
from medium body positivity or sorry
body positive is for women only whoa
what now let's look at some of the
movements that we've had again if you're
a man in this country let alone a white
man remember we had the hashtag believe
all women and uh you don't really hear
about what happened after you know UVA
Rolling Stone remember the mattress girl
that ruined that man's life he didn't
rape her she was trying to rape him the
Duke lacrosse team of course they were
they were fleece and they never get
their reputation back and that brings us
back to shame you know what really
matters to a lot of uh men out there
particularly white men who've been
working their name
the way that you ruin their life is not
just by taking the money it's by taking
their name and it's never been easier to
take someone's name and reputation than
today in social media we had the hashtag
me too let's use that as a perfect
example yeah Christine blasey Ford
remember she made up everything
about Brett Kavanaugh everything what
she told the Washington Post it wasn't
didn't make sense it wasn't in line or
consistent with what she told the police
officers that wasn't consistent with
what she told their friends and even if
you added it all up she claimed to be
raped at a party that had didn't happen
in a house that didn't even exist
and Brett Kavanaugh kept a journal
his entire life so it was all made up
the man's reputation was destroyed
still destroyed if you read right now
somebody will say this rapist Brett
Kavanaugh no punishment
that man lost his name I know what
you'll say well he's in the Supreme
Court guess what
that's not enough guess what no
guarantee you he has to live with this
for the rest of his life and men
out there who don't have the resources
and who aren't appointed to the Supreme
Court they just lose their name and
their Circle and their friends yeah and
they think that a shotgun in their mouth
is a way out and statistically it's a
problem that we're not dealing with
because the feminists out there and the
victim complex the professional victims
want you to ignore it yeah they get
shunned by society as a deadbeat right
in those situations right and Brett
Kavanaugh's kids by the way they're
they're going to deal with the fact
they're going to deal with that their
their dad had his name drugged through
the mud now I don't know what ages they
are but if they're in school still you
know it's going to get brought up all
the time and it doesn't even matter if
they're in the workplace it's going to
get brought up right never going to be
the same again and Men desire above
almost all else I think you can probably
look at the polls and see this like
respect is one of the top things that
men want not demand but just want right
they want to have respect they want to
be able to have that respect from people
now they feel like they have to earn it
that's fine we have to earn that respect
all of this takes that away yeah you
have no respect you have no name you're
a deadbeat you're a useless person to
society and by the way nobody's coming
to your Aid to help you get out of there
right so what's the point yeah if you're
a woman and you're uh your your BMI is I
mean it can't even we have to put you on
the Free Willy scale hey you're
beautiful if a man gets a couple of love
handles because he's been laid off and
he's been having to eat at Taco Bell for
it oh you're a lazy white guy with dad
bud this is and this is the brow beating
that takes place again it's not that
they're just ignoring right there are no
resources on the government hotline for
for white men it doesn't exist but it's
that they also attack you and this one
is is funny to me when I sort of did a
deep dive into the rabbit hole they
tried to tie men's rights directly to
white supremacy this is from straight
from Salon April 2023 it says war on
women the link between white supremacy
men's rights and anti-abortion what they
tied all three of those 16. you know
what's crazy the men's rights Community
you know you know who's most black men
yeah oh it's a huge component for black
men who talk about women you know who
didn't want to marry them who want child
support who use it uh not for the
children there's a huge component in the
black community I mean you have you have
shows you have a fit and fresh show I
just forgot I'm sorry the name of the
man who passed away
um
no no the Sam Samuel what does uh Kevin
Samuels Kevin Samuels yeah right there
are a lot of people like this so they
just ignore it when it's convenient war
on women the link between white
supremacy men's rights and anti-abortion
politics so what will happen is if
anyone talks about this right if we say
hey men are offering themselves in
alarming numbers really you're one of
those men's rights White supremacists
okay so you have that you're saying
Salon that's extreme right I'm a
Centrist all right let's go to as
mainstream as you can possibly get where
every single time and I'm speaking in
extremes here but most times let's call
it 90 the white guy shows up in the
commercial he's the idiot who can't
install blinds or worse
use it to make a white wine spritzer
perfect for hanging out with two chains
I love your rap music I have a
helicopter we should be going you don't
like boats I like boats and I love all
these seven up mixed drinks is this the
best a man can get
kiss cams on the prowl again he's alive
[Applause]
oh no man what the
you know what I never noticed this
also by the way if you watch a lot like
the home alarm commercials was it now
Simply Safe it's a white guy and a
hipster mustache breaking in at two in
the morning yeah yeah I saw that
for a second yeah you can go back to the
black and white and the gray issues
remember that one black guy said like
you know like why you know we're the
ones who are paying it negatively in
advertising this black guy said this I
said really I mean come on we're the
ones always painted as criminals he goes
well because you can't make it a black
guy you'd be really stepping into some
trouble I said okay so you acknowledge
it he goes yeah yeah pretty much
because it's the one group that's the
white man can be the butt of the Joker
no matter what it's in Nick de Paul I
don't know if we have the right clip
here but he did this is maybe he started
doing this 12 15 years ago this is why I
say you can watch them on mug Club 5 PM
Eastern it is a strong R this guy is the
OG
there's a reason that everyone in the
internet in comedy will tell you yeah
he's he's probably the best working
stand-up comic today people will tell
you that are at least top five he talked
about these kinds of ads 15 years ago
every commercial is gender neutral every
commercial has to be gender neutral I
heard this on the radio today okay I
swear to God the men and women have to
be equal no matter what the commercial
is this is the commercial it goes one in
four a man will be diagnosed with
prostate cancer this year but prostate
cancer affects you too ladies it does we
can't even have that to ourselves
oh we didn't include the rest of it it
gets pretty it gets probably because
we're not a strong R yeah no but he had
a bit 15 years ago I remember where he
said uh we were talking about AOL online
he goes you know there's this commercial
for AOL online it says it's so easy even
my dad can use it yeah you mean the guy
bought the computer you're selfish
little
every time we show up and I get it look
you may say oh who cares about a
commercial no it's the commercials it's
the headlines it's the body positivity
it's the fact that the government
doesn't provide any resources for white
men at a certain point it adds up to the
statistic that you really wish would go
away white men commit suicide white
women don't black people don't it's just
a fact statistically it's not even close
so systemic racism against white man
technically I wouldn't say it's systemic
it's a cultural uh it's a cultural
allowance if this is what's happened to
black people it's sustainable yeah you
forget Stephen he changed the definition
of racism that's true I forgot none of
it it's got to be again it's it's
against people of color though we're not
we have no color if the rose if the rows
were reversed and black man was coming
and you could go back to these
commercials oh you best believe this
right if black men were committing
suicide at nine times the rate of whites
because that's what's happening white
men nine times the rate nine they say a
systemic cause a lot of black people in
jail they're not in there
generally speaking
I'm sure they're probably a couple I saw
hurricane I've seen a couple white guys
go together with sins I've seen them
sure I saw one Asian guy yeah yeah it
happens it happens one just one one boom
boom go they call that the Asian block
yeah it's old Asian block D the one
Asian guy
that's a whole block to himself there's
actually a Twitter profile stupid white
ads that exist and the guy compiles dumb
white guy ads uh I guess he has over 80.
just since June of this year alone and
check it out
um and this is like it's just
fashionable in general and I'm not
saying that this is the primary reason
but it's fashionable in general just to
take a crap on on men including you know
men of all Races
um we know that right because even if
you watch I remember was watching parks
and recs where Parks and Rec and someone
said oh men's rights and Amy Poe said
that's not a thing it's not a thing
there's no such thing really well we'll
get into it we'll get into alimony we'll
get into what happens as far as custody
and child abuse but this is what they
say it's just there's no white men can't
because they're in a position of power
so it's okay to dump on them which is by
the way they've been remaking popular
films you see this the only thing that
they're doing think of the message is oh
Ghostbusters we're going to turn we're
going to turn Ghostbusters into all
women oh because that means that white
men and by the way also black men and
Ghostbusters that means that men are a
problem Ocean's eight well because
Ocean's Eleven even though it did have
women and even though it didn't have
black it had men so men are the problem
and there's even this new gym that
redoing Fight Club which is not I mean
hey
first rule of all female Fight
Club is
it's just the first rule it's just
this brings us to another uh key fact
here number five uh and I'm hoping that
you know we make all the references
available and there's a lot here to dive
into because I want you to be able to
use this in the future and I
particularly hope that this helps with
the demographic that commits suicide out
there know that they are not uh they are
not alone and there are resources so
let's look at some of the policy as it
relates to systemic discrimination
criminal sentencing right female
offenders of all Races receive far
shorter sentences for similar crimes
than white male offenders let's look at
custody and child support the mother is
the custodial parent 80 percent of the
time and by the way that is not because
it is not just because the men don't
want the children the courts just assume
that it's better for the mom to get the
children even if the women leave 68 of
the time if they have a college degree
it's about 80 of divorces are filed by
women and domestic abuse infidelity are
not even the top five reasons listed
then you look at the fact that mothers
when their divorce receive far more
child support than men on average
alimony 98 of people in this country who
receive alimony are women
and this is here here's something that
may shock you all of this is based on a
system a court system that says well the
woman should get alimony the woman
should get child support because women
mothers are inherently altruistic men
are violent and so they shouldn't be the
single parent or the custodian well the
fact is single mothers abuse children at
two times the rate of single fathers
geez I think it's somewhere but the
estimates are anywhere from 1.3 to 2.2
let's round it two times the rate
we'll do a whole segment on that too I'm
not comparing joint couple households to
single mothers single mothers two single
fathers in a single father household
they're less likely to be abused less
likely to develop a substance disorder
less likely to go into sex work more
likely to graduate high school but the
system says hey
you owe my money
and Mom gets the kids
and by the way even if she is abusing
the amount of proof the burden of proof
that is required is insurmountable again
take is this a situation that you've
never heard of happening man gets fired
and his wife leaves him
all of those things contribute
tweet dis a massively disproportionate
risk of suicide
and we have policies Concepts entirely
that have been weaponized against white
men and they've been increasingly forced
upon all of us I mean for crying out
loud white men in the United States have
to deal with Larry Fink
hmm at BlackRock we are forcing
behaviors 54 of the incoming class are
women we we added four more points in
terms of diverse uh employment this year
and it will if it you know what we're
doing it just means if you don't achieve
these levels of impact your compensation
could be impacted okay we're doing the
same thing and so it's just it you have
to force behaviors you have to force
behaviors and so here's what happens
right if you're and by the way this
applies to men in general but I will say
this particularly white men for this for
the same reason that there are no grants
there are no scholarships uh there are
no subsidies just based on being a white
man just let's do the flip side there
are scholarships and grants that exist
just for being black there are grants
scholarships or for example requirements
just for being a woman just for being
Asian just for being a black woman the
only place where it doesn't exist there
is no leg up subsidy grant that exists
just for being a white man it's the one
group you combine that with the fact
that the suicide resource line from our
government provides some kind of catered
resources to every demographic except
white men well here's the thing men feel
isolated and if men want to speak out
particularly white men you just heard
that from Larry Fink what happens is
they create these Concepts oh no white
male Supremacy that's one and then it's
no no wait white supremacy then it's
white privilege you have to check your
privilege then it's the overall
privilege of uh whiteness in general
then there are things like social
justice then there are issues like
unconscious bias then there's Dei
right then there's systemic rate no
matter where you are as a white male you
are told you can't don't come oh really
want to complain because you haven't had
it good for so long
and so white men suffer in silence
and die
yeah and Larry Fink when he made that
comment the other I believe CEOs on that
panel that we're talking right there
immediately one of them felt the need
and also felt that it was socially
acceptable to do it to jump in and say
yeah yeah we're doing the same thing too
right that was the expectation and by
the way white men are just listen I
understand that point that people are
like oh you know white men you haven't
had a heart I don't understand it being
true I understand why they would say
that because Society tells you that
white people have it very easy they put
out all of these fake statistics that we
come back and kind of debunk a little
bit but I've got some personal
experience with this like I've got
people in my family who have been in
their 50s that have lost their job that
are white men and they have gone out and
said you know what the only unprotected
class in the United States is straight
white middle-aged males now you could
probably expand it to just be outside of
middle age as well and still be accurate
but when you feel like the entire system
not that they don't have your back
because I'm willing to work for it and I
believe I believe most of those guys are
willing to work for it they're actively
looking at you as the problem yeah
though it's not just a you don't get the
services it's your part of the problem
just for being a straight white
middle-aged male yeah we have people by
the way out in this office who worked at
major companies
who were punished lost their job just
because they were a white male we have
white males we have some we've almost
not not anymore not after this show no
not after this show hey look and I want
to ask you and comment below because I'm
going to explain to you this is where
I'll put my Alex Jones hat on by the way
mug club uh every Friday you get to
watch Alex Jones here if you sign up but
uh before I I get there why do you think
all this is happening I'll I'll give you
a breakdown this too
um
a hunch
but to give you this was a Story I
played hockey with this guy's kids uh
this is in Montreal it used to be a
place called the Eaton Center people if
you're in Montreal you know what I'm
talking about it's this it's like they
call it the second City so in Montreal
there's a whole second City that goes
multiple floors I don't know if it's
five floors four floors six floors down
underground it's so cold no it really is
it's so cold so you can go from subway
stop to no you can do your groceries you
can you can shop there's a food court
movie theater and you never actually
have to you know pop your head up
underground yeah underground negative
30. yeah so there's this place the Eaton
Center and they're you know it goes
picture it going down almost looks like
Blade Runner I think they actually might
have shot uh might have filmed someone
can let me know if that's true uh Blade
Runner at some areas in this underground
area of Montreal
and there was a man who uh something
happened I believe he lost his is I
don't want to give details so I'll
change some identities here but I went
to I played hockey with his kids there's
a man who lost his job
and he ran a business and it was
basically going to blow up uh and I
think he was maybe in trouble with some
taxes taxes something like that and um
he did he he killed himself and everyone
was shocked I remember this because
everyone was was shocked but then they
looked in the security cameras at the
Eaton Center now he threw himself off
the railing down I believe four stories
and landed in the food court
which I think someone yelled check
please ruined lunch
I said no human
in my Hoagie but he jumped
spark yeah there you go so from the top
there you can't even see so top jumped
all the way yeah yeah that's all under
that's underground or the most of it and
everyone was shocked and I remember us
all going I can't believe that happened
but then they looked at the security
camera footage
and they found him for at least a week
before he actually jumped walking
that railing pacing for a week that man
that white man
what a piece of who went out and he
struck out and maybe he didn't pay some
taxes maybe he made some mistakes sure
but that man couldn't talk to anyone
about it
he lived in his own personal hell before
he decided it was better for his family
than to shame them than to lose his
reputation and tell them they would have
to move into another house and then
flung himself over that is just so you
that that seems dramatic because of how
he did it that is
most suicides in this country it's
middle-aged white men
who've lost their circle of friends
largely because they've lost their job
and they have been left
they have been abandoned by A system
that says that they should start off
from the default position of being a
villain so why does a system exist this
way
why do we have not just a divorcist not
just divorce family courts which we've
talked about not just Dei not just
affirmative action but culturally like
why do all of these things seem to
culminate in anti the group of people
who kill themselves well
one group in this country that
consistently reliably
never votes for the leftist agenda
white men voted Republican 61 versus 38
percent who didn't 92 percent of
conservative white men by the way voted
for Donald Trump
of course conservatism Champions uh
Champions a nuclear family
right I think that's really important
they call this white supremacy they call
this alt-right at one point once that
didn't stick I we actually had it's
coming up this Friday actually a new
black and white on the gray issues it
was a mother and her daughter the only
group of black individuals who decided
that merely talking was racist and they
said that the nuclear family I you
not they said the nuclear family is a
contra construct of white supremacist
patriarchy what this is what is being
taught in your schools you were there
tool man well they say that while being
in a nuclear
they were basically white Suburban
broads who happened to be black yeah to
private school told her the nuclear
family is a construct of patriarchy but
typically speaking you look at one
voting block who people talk about hey
maybe there'll be some inroads made with
black Americans hey Latinos are voting
Republican more than before it's pretty
much white males once they get beyond
the age of 35 they're going to be the
consistent conservative voting block the
left hasn't even really tried to reach
them they try to do it with white
privilege they try to do it but it is it
is the last defense
is white males in this country if you
look as a voting block against
overarching government in preserving the
first amendment in preserving the Second
Amendment in believing in nuclear
families believing in strong male
figures believing in yep
complementarianism
in relationships
and that same demographic is attacked
relentlessly from all fronts from the
government from your media
from culture at Large
to the point that they commit suicide at
four times the rate of women
and eight to nine times the rate of
black Americans hey I'm just saying at a
certain point right statistics can be
massaged but there's kind of some
finality to Suicide isn't there
I'd like you to comment here below
really quickly but
whoever you've
um
had the unfortunate experience of maybe
being being touched by Sue I think all
of us have been touched by Suicide or
attempted suicide somewhere in our lives
um
again 92 percent of workplace deaths are
men that's a fact
and then white males specifically 70 of
the suicides despite paying about 30 of
the population five times the rate
compared to white women or four times
the rate nine times the rate compared to
Black Americans
it's a real problem
and the good news is it's the easiest
problem to start solving
it really is now on a macro level needs
to start with listening
needs to start with hey hold on a second
hold on a second we can't just say that
white men shouldn't complain about their
Pro they seem to be legitimate why do
you think they're legitimate because
they're killing themselves in other
words they're not writing an article
they're they don't have a sub stack they
don't have a tumbler they're not going
on Instagram to they're blowing
their heads off because of their
problems and we're telling them that
their problems aren't real
think about that for a second so what
can you do on an individual level look
like we've said the enemy of of joy is
isolation it's not good for man to be
alone that starts in Genesis by the way
that's why oh sexist God gave man woman
they were meant to be together because
it's not good for man to be alone so
please if you are considering this or
you think that don't it's a cliche but
it really is true
don't don't turn to a permanent solution
for a temporary problem get involved
with local community groups reach out to
church leaders reach out to friends and
family reach out to people who by the
way will actually listen and not ask you
to check your white privilege I'm going
to tell you this if you were thinking if
you're a white male and you were
actually thinking about harming yourself
don't go to someone who's going to guilt
you for simply being a white male get
involved with maybe some men's rights
groups there are those that exist out
there single dads groups I know the left
right now will try and throttle this and
say that that's white male Supremacy
what I'm saying is you need to discuss
this problem with people who have been
through it and people who can provide
you support and not tell you that you're
just a lazy white guy with Dad thought
which maybe means you have oh my God
gone through the horror of ballooning up
to 13 body fed hey do a dexa scan with
the who told you that let's see
how it turns out hit the like button
comment below let's get her in the
saline pool
it's go what are you about to say by the
way so I know I got a little seriously
we're gonna play hate symbol or not on
mug Club but you know I just yeah oh my
gosh we're all going to a place that I
don't want to go that's very hot no look
I we have to address Algeria no now
um Africa I said South Africa oh okay
different no I think it's important to
do that I wasn't kidding I've had you
know this person that I mentioned too
that had an issue that is a family
member of ours and felt like in suicidal
ideation Suicidal Thoughts had all kinds
of like well my life is over I had a
successful career now what do I do you
know and and it was it's very difficult
so I'm glad that we dove into it and
used numbers that are irrefutable so I
hope people take this very seriously I
know we went long today covering it but
that's okay right this is a very very
big issue one thing I do want to say
though is that you're wrong Stephen
black and white airs on Thursday not
Friday oh did I say Friday admonish me
really quickly guys admonish but it's
fun to admonish admonish me admonishes
admonish
again are you getting sucked off no that
stop it
managed admonish the twins yes and minus
the twins you have Munch Keith
okay stop oh God don't do it no see I
was being I was being playful you were
being vulgar yeah it's black yeah
it's black
um and look we went long we're able to
discuss this look I will tell you this
we had Cassie Jan the show Karen strong
very long before people were talking
about those episodes always get
throttled yeah it's considered hateful
for men to Simply discuss these issues
uh to discuss these issues that's why we
have Mud Club we can talk about it and
hey maybe it'll be throttled down to
only 50 000 plays and credit I don't
give a rat's ass if that reaches 40 000
people who need to hear it do consider
supporting it live with credit.com mug
club or you can watch the free portion
Monday through Friday 10 a.m Eastern
right now we're going to play hate
symbol or not or you know what maybe we
let's see what the chats are maybe
people want to talk about the suicide
issue more today
um considering that it it was a bit of I
hate to use the term deep dive we always
use the term meat segment but now the
popular term is deep dive deep dive yeah
let's unpack this
let's delve into this yes exactly
listen I don't like that you're
appropriating a white voice while doing
that as well hey you guys too black hey
you should mix you know what's happening
they do the voice like this we all talk
like this
all right but white people don't talk
like that I know we don't thank you yeah
it's what I needed to hear black people
Rumble thank you you can hit that button
join mug club and YouTube uh we know
that the segments probably got your goat
piss off
[Applause]
[Music]